welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to this is it we're in the endgame
now the culmination of 11 years of the
MCU is upon us with Avengers endgame and
if you've seen the film then you'll know
that there's a lot to unpack from it
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down the movies ending as well as the
main plot points of the story and giving
my thoughts on it this is of course full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen
endgame yet and don't want to know what
happens then I highly suggest that you
turn off now Disney did a wealth of fake
trailers so you probably don't know as
much as you think and the film deserves
to be seen unspoiled this is your last
last last chance to back out but if
you're still here thank you for clicking
the video I hope you enjoy it now let's
get into the full pop breakdown of
Avengers endgame Avengers end game opens
with Hawkeye training its daughter with
a bow and arrow at a picturesque family
picnic before they themselves are made
targets and are mercilessly taken out by
the snap instantly this grounds the film
and reminds you that even heroes who
haven't had anything to do with the
infinity war have been left victims by
it we then cut to Tony and nebula adrift
in space with the former recording his
message to pepper
Tony falls asleep and awakens to see
Captain Marvel outside of the ship who
helps them return to Earth which is
where they meet up with the rest of the
survivors the film doesn't feature the
post-credits scene from Captain Marvel
standalone movie so from that we can
guess that she arrived on earth and then
heard Tony was missing and spent the
rest of the time searching for them in
space now we'd heard rumors that Tony
and nebula make out of the situation
using annual axe batteries that Rockets
stolen guardians - so I think this feels
like a bit of a disservice to Tony's
ingenuity being rescued by Captain
Marvel instead of saving themselves as
the only criticism with the film that
had though and I suppose it speeds up
the character introductions the movie
then follows the surviving Avengers
attempting to track down Thanos whose
location is given away by nebula because
she knows of a garden that he said he
would retire to upon completing his
final goal they want to get the gauntlet
back no matter
cost and reversed the snap Tony however
doesn't want to be part of it and his
film expertly showcases Downey's range
of emotions when acting and he get the
feeling that he just wants to leave it
all behind and start a game the rest of
the group journey to Thanos his planet
and arrived to find him alone and he
informs them that he used the gauntlet
to destroy the stones because he doesn't
want anyone to change his decision the
look of this scene is ripped straight
out of the comics even down to the fruit
that Thanos collects and it's an amazing
easter egg unfortunately for Thanos the
second power surge nearly killed him and
he's very very weak Thor goes for the
head this time
killing him in the process and they
returned to earth which is when we
fast-forward five years at this point
the world is in complete disrepair
everything is rundown and those who've
been left behind are bitter and there
are rumors that Hawkeye is acting as a
vigilante and massacring gangs whilst
the Avengers still operate many of them
are broken especially Black Widow and
you get the feeling that she would do
anything to set the world straight again
which plays into her character arc and
eventual sacrifice
Captain Marvel returns to space as many
other planets are destroyed and we get a
nice little Joe Russo cameo at the
survivors meeting held by Captain
America cut to Louise's van which is
inside a storage unit and after a rat
crawls over the quantum controls Scott
is freed we follow him as he walks the
streets confused as to why everything
looks like 28 days later before he
arrives at a memorial with all of the
names of the vanished on a large stone
after reuniting with his daughter and
discovering what's happened he goes to
the only place he knows that can make a
difference
Avengers HQ have to tell them about the
quantum realm and it's time manipulation
possibilities they visit Tony to ask for
help but he turns them down as he's
happy with life
Bruce has also become Professor Hulk and
he helps the Avengers build a machine to
find the stones in the past
unfortunately the machine is faulty so
Scott can't go back which is when Tony
returns giving cap his shield and
stating that he will help what I love
about this section is that it's
showcases that star can't rest when he
knows something is wrong
watching Downey jr. grapple with a
choice of losing the life he loves or
granting one for everyone else is
inspired and he really becomes the hero
of the film from this point onwards
together they recruit the rest of the
Avengers including Hawkeye war machine
nebula and door who looks like he was
ripped straight out of The Big Lebowski
they traveled through time to different
parts of Avengers history and there are
some amazing callbacks cameos and an
incredibly hard touching moment between
Tony and his father in which they
discuss parenting a young Stanley also
makes an appearance as well as Peggy
Carter Hank Pym solar the Avengers
director Pierce and more Jarvis as well
I had to add that a because damn that
moment was just amazing
I've seen some critics say that this
segment is far too full of fanservice
but honestly when it's at this level
it's absolutely amazing everything feels
perfect and even the most obscure
reference such as caps sing hail Hydra
gets a nod this section allows each
character to realize what they've lost
and what they're fighting for and I love
the emotional loss that Thor feels when
meeting his mother on the day that she
would die balance with the comedic
dancing a Peter quill in the opener of
guardians it's also at this point that
the main threat of Thanos returns
whilst Marvel teased and even bigger
threatened Thanos they were ultimately
fooling us depending on how you look at
it younger Thanos is perhaps more
bloodthirsty and the awareness of their
plan coupled with the loss of Black
Widow at this point really hammers home
just how high the stakes are though they
retrieve the stones as at a cost and
even when Hulk returns everyone by
snapping his fingers you get the feeling
that it's only causing a new level of
danger past arrows is pulled through the
portal by nebula and he completely
devastates the base he states that he
realizes the flaw in his plan and that
the people that are left behind by the
snap will always feel loss therefore the
only choice he sees is to reduce all
life in the universe to a single atom
and to start again in his image
in infinity war thany stated that he
never wished to become a god but it's
clear that he did and even the world
being created in six days and having God
rest on the seventh is similar to
thousands goal of collecting six stones
and resting at the end of it in the end
Captain America Thor and Tony team up
against Thanos
but dannis beats them pretty mercilessly
just as he's about to kill Thor cap
manages to wield Thor's hammer and uses
it to smash you
Danah summons his entire army including
the Black Order and it looks like cap is
gonna be all along which is when he
hears Sam's voice and pretty much
everyone returns and they charge him
this is a phenomenal moment and I really
can't hammer home just how good this
looks on the big screen
during this Hawkeye has managed to get
the Infinity Gauntlet which gets passed
about is the sort of MacGuffin with
everyone trying to get it eventually
Captain Marvel arrives destroy Stannis
his ship and takes it but Thanos
wrestles it off her which is when Tony
realizes why Doctor Strange sacrificed
the time stone in infinity war in
exchange for his life he then snaps his
fingers wiping out all of the nurses
forces and tunnels himself Tony heavily
damaged by the gauntlet is finally able
to rest after being reassured by pepper
that everyone is okay at his funeral a
holographic Tony gives a message to
everyone including his daughter everyone
is there including the young boy from
Iron Man 3 who's all grown up which I've
seen some people get confused about but
it's definitely him
so I thought touching that Thor
designates Valkyrie as the queen of
Asgard and he joins the guardians of the
galaxy renaming them that as guardians
of the galaxy it's clear that Quayle is
looking for Gamora who is brought to the
Future I can definitely see that a root
being the direction that guardians three
goes down cap goes on a mission to
return the stones to their proper places
and Hulk says that he should be back in
five seconds but he doesn't return at
this moment Sam and Bucky see an old man
sitting at a bench and they realize it's
cap steve has a wedding ring on and he
also passes his shield to Sam who's
honored to take up the mantle we then
cut to a young Captain America dancing
with Peggy Carter
at the house which there wasn't a dry
eye in the house at this point Steve
finally got that dance that he promised
to make all the way back in the first
Avengers and it's just an amazing moment
he call back to that scene so what could
happen going forward well Sam and Bucky
are due to appear in a Marvel spin-off
series and Loki who manages to escape
confinement in this film with the
tesseract will also be getting his own
show I can see these two interweaving
and of course vision will be rebuilt to
star in the new show one division
overall Steve getting to live the life
that he did showcases that everyone
deserves happiness
Tony though apparently selfish sometimes
became selfless much in the same way
cap did so that cap could enjoy life
much in the same way that Tony did in
those five years of happiness whilst
Tony died it is the way of people to do
so and Morgan provides the future that
he always wanted to have surrounded by
those who can inspire and love her much
in the same way that he did it's an
amazing message and one that really
pulls at your heartstrings the film
doesn't have a post-credits scene but in
all honesty it doesn't need to this is a
perfect closing of a book that was
started way back in 2008 dr. strange
said that there were 14 million
different possibilities and out of all
of them this is the best one we could
have got the movie is a masterpiece from
start to finish and feels like an
achievement that won't be topped in
cinema for a long time I cried multiple
times laughed out loud on several
occasions and also felt a great sense of
joy when leaving the theater that I
haven't had since the Dark Knight
trilogy concluded this is an amazing
film and easily one of the best if not
the best comic book movie ever made
the end game ended perfectly and I can't
wait to watch it again
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and if you agree with me
comment below and let me know your
review and if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my breakdown of the entire
leaked plot so you can see what was
right and what wasn't this is a channel
for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]